good evening
six years after the brexit referendum
two and a half years after that brexit
deal
but now are britain's relations with the
eu at a lower point than ever
after months of speculation this week it
happened the prime minister and cabinet
announced plans to change the northern
ireland protocol the furious retaliation
from the eu has been swift they're
taking britain to court could we be on
the threshold of a full-scale trade war
just at the time when the economy can
bear it the least i'll be talking to
maro sefkovic the eu's chief negotiator
also tonight nicholas sturgeon's
government in scotland launched a new
campaign for independence this week a
radical new plan or the same old tune
that was defeated back in 2014. i'll
talk to the man who led his country
closer to independence than anyone else
alex salmond a lot has happened to mr
salmond since then what does he make of
his former proteges new push
and what is it like to be held in an
egyptian jail activist sana safe was
sentenced to 18 months for spreading
false news her brother's still being
detained in and out of prison in egypt
for his role in the arab spring uprising
of 2011.
sana and her family are fighting for his
release but should the british
government be helping two the family are
after all british citizens we hear their
story
the brexit agreement was put into
turmoil this week when the government
here decided to override the northern
ireland protocol the eu commissions
called it unrealistic i went to brussels
to speak to vice president maris sekovic
and get his reaction
vice president thanks for talking to us
today um let's start with the try and
week it's the difficult week but before
we do
can we reflect a bit or you reflect on
your the relationship between london and
brussels how bad do you think the
current uk eu
relations are now compared with
recent history
from one side i have to say that our
cooperation on ukraine and global
challenges is remarkable this is how you
would like
to see it because i always repeat that
for us
the uk
is a strategic partner it's ally it's
eternal neighbor and it's a very
important commercial
partner as well so we would like really
to kind of move our relationship on the
greener posture to really have that very
well functioning
bilateral relationship and of
course uh therefore i have to say
that if you are
going to discuss still the pertinent
brexit issues a pity that we have to
spend
so much time on them especially when we
need to build and consolidate this
western unity is the brexit difficulties
bleeding into other areas of cooperation
is it cast in a shadow it is because of
course uh the eu uk relationship is is
very it's very massive i mean so we
cooperate on lots of fields and if you
have
um the situation where after
very arduous and difficult negotiations
and
uh agreement on
the agreements like uh withdrawal
agreement uh
northern northern ireland protocol and
then of course
the trade and cooperation agreement and
we thought that we've done that we
agreed upon it we ratified it and we are
still talking about it and of course
what is extremely sensitive for us and
what what is indeed very damaging for
our relationship is this uh
constant breaching of the of the
international law and that's something
what we've been not used to
from the uk
on the breaching and and that making it
difficult from a european union
perspective over the past few days
members of the european parliament and
the darling island have said they can't
trust prime minister boris johnson or
foreign secretary liz truss their words
not to be taken is that your view as
well on that foundation we built the
trade and cooperation agreement it's
very much based on trust because i think
for the first time in the history of the
european union we actually accepted
that the external controls and checks on
our external border will be actually
performed by uk authorities this
you know breaching of the international
law makes it very difficult and
and it's very damaging to the travel
mutual trust does it make it difficult
for you to trust these people when
you're trying to negotiate i always
do the positive attitude
to my interlocutors and and i have
always respect for them because
they are representing their country
they're representing the the political
political interest and i always hope for
the better i mean that's i think what
the diplomats need to do but of course
i have to say that since march of the of
the last year we have uh permanent uh
threat of unilateral measures article uh
16
announcements and now we have
the draft bill which is clearly illegal
and which is of course making uh
our life here very difficult and
therefore i hope that with the proposals
which we put
on the table yesterday we flashed them
and in very concrete form that we can
bring our uk partners back to the
negotiating table because i think we
need to find the good solution well
let's let's get on to some of the
proposals that the uk and the european
union have suggested uh you you just
said it again you you are convinced that
the uk has acted illegally in laying
this legislation in you the uk
parliament that will overwrite parts of
the uh the northern ireland protocol
agreed in the withdrawal treaty by the
european union and the uk back in 2020
to quote your comments yesterday you
said there's no legal or political
justification whatsoever for changing
unilaterally an international agreement
the uk
government you know has a very different
perspective to you they say that this
has legal justification they use the
doctrine of necessity in international
law which allows a state to act in the
event of a grave risk to their interests
which is what the uk government has
concluded so i put it to you that that
might be your perspective but that's
certainly not the perspective of the
government in london i honestly think
that you don't have to be a lawyer to
see that this draft is clearly illegal
and i just would give you one very clear
example i mean there is
no way
that the uk will decide what kind of
goods
may enter into the european
single market
our uk counterparts they knew perfectly
well what they are signing up to and i
have to say that if it comes to the
northern ireland specific solution the
northern ireland
protocol it was expressed wish of this
uk government so they they been
negotiating with us
line by line we've been jointly looking
for the solutions how to protect peace
in northern ireland how to avoid
the hard border how to make sure the
good friday belfast agreement is
respected in all its dimension and the
the protocol was the result so that's
that's the only solution after arduous
negotiation and looking at it from from
from all the sites which is now being
undermined so what what we are offering
here is permanent solution usa is
following this very very closely i mean
when i was
in washington dc a couple of months ago
i have to say that this was the question
which was featured quite prominently in
all the meetings i had
in white house
the state department and especially in
the congress and it was just a couple of
weeks ago we had very important
congressional delegation here
and first and foremost what is the most
important for united states as it is for
us to maintain the peace
respect the good friday belfast
agreement and to sort it out the usa
have made it clean clear to you that
they also do not support the uk's
unilateral action what i heard from our
u.s partners always was work together
work for the joint solutions and
especially
in in congress but also in the state
department and um in uh
in the white house
they they know
that the protocol is the answer but they
want us to work out on how to smooth
more the operation how to uh address
this unintended consequence and this is
exactly what what we are proposing to do
but to deliver that we need engagement
and political will from london and vice
president i want to get into a bit of
the sort of sticking points between the
uk
and brussels at the moment but but but
from a uk perspective and you will know
this the protocol isn't working in that
the uk government's job is to uphold the
good friday group you just said it was
the most important thing for all parties
but power sharing in northern ireland is
not happening
and that's as a direct consequence of
the protocol
i mean
the government has to do something if
they can't get power sharing working in
northern ireland you you accept that
don't you
of course we do not want to interfere in
the internal politics of uk and northern
ireland i think uh it's for the people
of northern ireland to decide on all
these very important issues where we see
our task is just to
recall that
the first two articles in the protocol
on ireland northern ireland are
about full respect of the good friday
belfast agreement in all its dimension
and second one is on uh full respect of
uh territorial integrity and
constitutional arrangements of the uk
and we fully respect that what
uh where we differ is the fact that we
see
that the protocol is actually the the
the solution
uh for maintaining the peace for
protecting the good friday belfast
agreement and for avoiding the hard
border and bringing this
additional prosperity to the northern
ireland
economy and
therefore we are in i would say
permanent contact with the key
stakeholders in northern ireland just to
present them our view of all these
developments but the key here are the
unionists as you know the democratic
union's party will not enter the parish
sharing arrangement with the protocol as
it stands and they want wholesale
changes hence the government's
legislation they need to get this work
and they need to get the northern
ireland assembly have you spoken to the
dep about your proposals this week i
have to say that we are in in i would
say permanent contact with the key
stakeholders in
northern ireland beat northern irish
business leaders civic society but also
political leaders and
i invited
all political leaders
to talk to us and i'm ready to talk to
them at any time i have met uh in the
past several times with sergio free
and i was underlining one very important
things that we want
to deliver or on all
unintended consequences of the protocol
and we want to do it in a constructive
way what we do not need is a political
victory in in this in these debates
i uh we are not here for political
scoring that the eu is right and you
prevailed in these negotiations we
really want to solve the problem
vice president you you said though just
to pick up on that that the eu are not
into political point scoring do you
think that the uk government is partly
doing this for political point scoring
i cannot
resist the impression that
the tabling of the build is politically
driven
but it's not our role to comment on
internal politics in the in the uk and
therefore uh our doors for the
negotiations will always be open i'm
ready to talk to all political leaders
in northern ireland to all stakeholders
and and to work on uh
what is the only solution in this uh
difficult situation and this is joint
approach these are the permanent
solutions vice president you just said
that you think it could be
something to do with domestic politics
in the uk you suggesting what do you
mean by that what are you suggesting
i think that uh what
currently uh we would very much uh
appreciate this uh the more of a
political will to work uh on these
issues
you don't think the prime minister of
the uk does you think that there's
another agenda he's following here
i wouldn't i wouldn't comment on
domestic politics in the uk but what i
can tell you is that
already in february
we proposed to our
uk partners a quite
detailed roadmap what do you think we
should discussed on technical expert
level
um
in in the period of pre-election uh
campaign
uh in in northern ireland and until
today we didn't get the response so what
i want to say if this issue is so urgent
why uh we didn't use the time more
efficiently why we didn't work on these
joint solutions and yesterday you
announced you'd resume previously paul's
legal action
against uk for failing to implement the
border checks for goods arriving from ni
to gb
i put it to you that that doesn't really
resolve anything it just it it just
escalates the situation further
what i have to say is that
as you know we we put our legal action
in freezer last year
and it was also the gesture of a
goodwill from from our side because we
wanted to create conducive space for
there for the negotiations but as i told
you there was a radio silence from
london since february we got this
unilateral
draft bill which is really damaging the
trust in our relationship and we just
simply have to defend our interests so
we have to start
the legal action but again what is very
important to underscore uh we would act
proportionate we would be
gradual in our responses because we want
to keep doors open and we still hope
that we will
get our uk partners back to the
negotiating table can you rule out a
trade war i think you're saying you
can't what i want to say is that we've
been building our new post-brexit
relationship
on very clear fundament and first one
was visual agreement part of it is the
protocol
island in northern ireland and on this
uh two fundamental pieces we built the
trade and cooperation agreement but if
you pull the rack
from under the feet of this of this of
this of this construction then of course
we have a fundamental issue
uh with the
you know the whole architecture and
therefore we cannot exclude anything so
you can't exclude a trade war
if you're boris johnson in london uh
listening to this you're thinking yeah
yeah trade war could come in 33 years
time is your the eu process right so
three years time is after the next
election i mean in a way politically
it's it's meaningless in that it's a
it's a it's an empty threat isn't it
at this point in in negotiations
we are not in the business of threats as
as a eu and uh from the i mean moment
one when we've been negotiating this
travel agreement protocol tca we've been
the only party i have to say which was
bringing constructive ideas to the table
and we did it in the course of the last
year despite the lots of universal
unilateral elections taken uh by the uk
and we are doing it now it was a i would
say a big part of our presentation
yesterday was what we
uh offer uh to solve this problem how
this can be done and the proposition as
we put on the table will tick i would
say uh uh all the all the all the boxes
on what we hear uh from the northern
ireland if it comes to sps controls if
it comes to the customs
procedures and on top of it will will
bring back
permanent solution will bring back
the access to the biggest trading block
in the in the world and
i think would really calm down the the
atmospherics between the eu and the uk
let me put it another way then you
you can't take the threat of a trade war
off the table i know you don't like the
word threat
but you but you don't really think it's
it it's likely you think that there can
be a solution before each side neither
side wants that as the outcome do they
you think you can work this out of
course it would be our uh it would be
our preference i mean therefore we we
went into this very special i would say
uh institutional and agreement set up
with the uk which really i'm parallel as
i as i would remind and recall once
again we asked the uk to perform the
checks on the goods which are entering
european single market how much more we
can demonstrate our our trust and we
need uh you know that this would be uh
this would be done according to the
according to the to the rules and of
course we would prefer to have uh
fructose normal relationship with the
with the uk but at the same time
we also have to defend our interests
vice president i just want to bring you
quickly on something else regarding that
on the checks there would be some in the
uk government that think
they're not enforcing checks now and
they just don't enforce any checks so
you're in a situation where the uk
government won't enforce any checks
checks on goods uh going uh north south
on the island of ireland so going from
the from the european from the uk into
the european union what are you going to
do
if the uk government did that would you
at any point
put any
checks on the border north south at hard
border on the side is that a possibility
do you absolutely rule that out
i'm absolutely ruling out the hard
border
and
of course this would be additional i
would say illegality in our relationship
and we will just
discuss with the with the member states
and with the european parliament what
should be the course of further action
because indeed
we
have to make sure that public health
not only of
the people in the european union but
also in the people in the northern
ireland is not under the threat and here
maybe one additional point which i would
like to make until now
um
i have to say that the convergence
uh between the rules in the in the in in
the uk and the eu
been
rather big but if of course uk would
proceed
with this divergence agenda and the
standards
would simply be more wider apart then
it could be of course a more and more
problematic question and therefore
i think it's it's quite important to
stick to what we agreed upon
that if it comes to northern ireland it
would it would have access to the single
market and that access is based on
respecting the eu rules
just quickly though you you've clearly
ruled out a hard border on the island of
ireland north south what about the idea
of checkpoints
or border posts or so but you rule out
all of that no checks no cameras nothing
on the border
i mean we we asked for the border
points between gb and and northern
ireland and that was the uh
that's that was clearly the the part of
the agreement and
and that's
actually
one
issue
which we are complaining about in our
legal
legal legal action
and
this is uh how we agreed that we would
solve and therefore we want to stick to
the international law to the agreement
we have signed
just to round up um
how confident are you that this can be
resolved you did publish some
suggestions on customs this week it does
seem that the uk intransigence has
helped move
the european union a bit do you do you
think that we can resolve this
and that the european union and the uk
can properly move on and put brexit to
bed
i think
here we have to follow the the very
common rule
hope for the best be prepared for the
worst
this is what
we will be we will be doing here
and
we will be
permanently pointing
to the huge advantages of our approach
over unilateral
proposals which came from the uk because
we really have uh
the
the interests of people of northern
ireland in heart
we
absolutely want to make sure that they
would benefit
from the access to the single market
from having the possibility to export to
500 million people and we want
to provide them with legal certainty
with clarity with stability and
for these goals we are ready to work
with uk government and with all um
political leaders in northern ireland
okay vice president thank you very much
i hope the talks do resume soon and and
uh we'd love to talk to you again in a
few months see how things are going
thank you thank you very much for
inviting me